- Your sky and my sky might be different,
you know what I mean?
But neither of us will touch the sky
if we give ourselves boundaries.
The one thing I really
like to do is drama.
If I aspired to be on the
levels Denzel Washington
and the Robert De Niros of the world,
I had to reinvent myself.
Whatever I try and do, I
do it from a point of view
as, do I believe in it?
Yes.
I think that, you know, if
you're an acting student,
you know, be a student of the game.
Understand the game as much as you can.
Oh, look at that monster!
- Yeah (laughs).
- Do you see it yet?
Actually, if I can see myself doing that,
I could probably do it.
One thing I kept doing
is inspiring myself,
looking for inspiration and growing.
Oh God, I want to walk into rooms
where people have been,
lived, seen, smelled,
touched, felt Mr. Mandela.
There was a drive to be famous,
to be that pinnacle, to be that guy.
- He's a British actor, musician, and DJ.
He's best known for his
portrayal of the drug lord
on the HBO series The Wire.
He's been nominated five
times for a Golden Globe
for best actor in a miniseries.
He's Idris Elba and here are
his top 10 rules for success.
(loud explosion)
I mean, it's important not
to give yourself boundaries,
which we can do quite easily, okay?
People talk about aiming for the skies.
Sometimes even aiming for
the skies is intimidating.
Just don't give yourself boundaries.
Your sky and my sky might be different,
you know what I mean?
But neither of us will touch
the sky if we give ourselves
boundaries, you know what I mean?
Whatever your sky is, whatever
your biggest dream is,
I might have already
touched that, you know?
So in other words, what sky?
Where does the sky end?
I'd rather people go, "You know what?
"I'm not going to
restrict myself to going,
"'I can only do this
or I can only do that,
"'or I have to do it this way
or I have to do it that way.'"
I think it's important
that people just go,
"I'm going to lose the boundaries,
"lose the conformity, and just go for it."
It was a real sort of liberating feeling
at 16, 17 years old.
The one thing I really
liked to do was drama
and there was no sort of
beacon for this could be
a career, you could do it.
I just didn't see that, but
I really loved to do it,
so I just said, "I want
to do what I love,"
you know what I mean?
- So it was like,
school plays or did you?
- Yeah, school plays
and from school, you know, literally,
my fear.
My drama teacher was like,
"You got some talent here,
"brother, you know?
"You did really well on your GCSEs.
"You got some talent.
"Why don't you do it?"
And she gave me this course.
There's a two-year performing arts course.
It was a new course.
And she's like, "Do the
course, fall on your face
"for two years, paint scenery,
"direct plays, just do it for two years
"and see if you like it."
And that's what I did.
That's when I fell in love with it.
So I got to a certain point in my career
where I saw the glass ceiling.
I was so close to it, I was
going to hit my forehead on it,
but I was busy.
I was busy.
I got lots of work.
I realized that I could only
play so many best friends
or gang leaders, all right?
I knew that I wasn't going
to land a leading role.
I knew there wasn't enough imagination,
not yet, for the industry
to be seeing me as a lead.
In other words, if I wanted
to star in a British drama
like Luther, for example,
then I'd have to go to a
country like America, all right?
Now some people might say back then,
"Look, there was no black detectives?
"You know, like, how can you expect us
"to make a TV show about one?"
It's television!
(audience laughs)
Sorry.
And the other thing is
that I didn't see myself
or my culture on TV, so I literally
just stopped watching it.
Instead, I decided to go and become TV.
Now if I aspired to be on the levels
of Denzel Washingtons and the
Robert De Niros in the world,
I had to reinvent myself.
I had to transform the
way the industry saw me.
I had to climb out of that box.
In other words, I didn't go to America
because I couldn't get parts.
I went to America because
I was running out of parts.
All the parts were the same.
Whatever I try and do, I do
it from a point of view as,
do I believe in it?
Yes.
I don't do things for money
and I've been broke most of my life.
So because of that,
I can't sort of suddenly go,
"I need to do a job
just to get some cash,"
you know what I mean?
I know that's, a lot of times,
it is people's motivations
because people do need to eat,
but in my position,
I've been poor most of my life,
so now, I don't really
do things based on money.
I do things based on
authenticity of how I feel.
I think that, you know, if
you're an acting student,
you know, be a student of the game,
understand the game as much as you can.
It's very important to know the territory
that you want to be in.
If it's a film director, or an actor,
or whatever that is, really understand
what you're trying to
achieve and understand
the marketplace, if you like.
There's nothing worse than an actor
that has grandiose ideas of being famous
but doesn't actually
understand the root it takes
to get from one place
to another as an actor.
So that's about self-education, of course
and trying to put
yourself in opportunities
where you can always practice your craft,
whether that's doing small plays,
whether that's writing
scripts for yourself,
whether that's audition
and doing open auditions.
As a young actor,
try as much as you can to
be around the community
of filmmakers and theater
so you can soak it all up like a sponge.
- I feel like coming off
a movie like Pacific Rim
where you're using language
and you're talking about
things that aren't real,
you're doing that, and
I'm sure some of the stuff
you're talking about you don't even know
what you're talking about, right?
(Idris laughs)
To go from that to
something that is so real
- Yeah.
- What's the transition
like in your head?
- [Idris] I mean, it was nuts actually
because I was here shooting that film,
going off and talking about,
"Oh, look at that monster!"
- Yeah (laughs).
- Do you see it yet?
And then reading about Mr. Mandela
and having to prepare for that.
That was a massive contrast for me
and I think it is really,
it's, you know,
if a guitarist picks up a guitar
and he can play a reggae
song and a rock song
using the one instrument,
that's the beauty
of the instrument and that's, I think,
the beauty of an actor,
is being able to do that
- Right.
- And have that sort of span,
you know?
I think my imagination's
always kept me going,
you know what I mean?
It's like, just imagine myself
collecting awards.
Just imagine myself getting big parts.
Imagine myself working
with the greatest actors.
My imagination was the one like,
you know what I mean?
Not overthink it, but
you're just kind of like,
"Yeah man, I see myself
driving that car one day,"
and I get that, you know what I mean?
That's part of my "inner magic,"
is that actually, if I
can see myself doing that,
I could probably do it.
So you can't bottle it up
and sell it to somebody.
You either can do it or you can't,
but everybody can imagine themselves,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah, you know what?
Actually, yeah.
I can see myself being
an influencer in clothes,
you know what I mean?
Because I can make that happen.
Yes, you know my history of being sort of
on all sides of my journey.
I didn't have success very early
and I went through some very dark times
and do you know what I mean?
One thing I kept doing
is inspiring myself,
looking for inspiration and growing,
and it hasn't stopped and
I want to keep doing that.
And I also
want to inspire others, you know?
There are millions of me
sitting at home right now
and they don't know it
and it's just good to be able to get
this sort of platform to sort of say,
"Come on, man.
"Go for it."
There was a lot of encouragement to trust
my instincts, you know?
The instinct of use your presence,
you know what I'm saying?
And like, in South Africa, you know.
Obviously, I'm not South African,
so I'm really aware that
oh God, I'm going to walk
into rooms where people have been, lived,
seen, smelled, touched, felt Mr. Mandela
in person, on the radio, on television.
And here I come as an outsider doing this
portrayal of him.
I was really aware.
It used to make me really nervous about
if I'm going to do it right or not
and Justin
encouraged me to stay
with what my gut was.
Just stay with that.
Don't waver from it, don't
try to be their Mandela
or the Mandela they think you should be.
Be that guy we've discussed
in all the rehearsals
and all the script meetings, you know?
Be that guy, go with that thing.
So that was great, actually.
I took Justin's credit.
Like, he really helped
me sculpt and measure out
that performance, you know?
I was 16
contemplating being an actor.
I was in Sound Systems
DJing, you know what I mean?
And it was like, that or this?
So I always go back to DJing.
I always have a studio, always
have turntables, always.
- [Interviewer] Your feet firmly fell
planted on the ground?
- Are they?
I don't know.
- [Interviewer] Well, I don't know.
Actors, it's hard.
- It is and.
- It's hard to get
all this attention and stay sane.
- Yeah.
I think, you know what I mean?
Like for me, listen.
I've been doing it a long time.
You know what I mean?
And there was a drive
to be famous,
to be that pinnacle, to be that guy
and I'm not.
My ambition isn't that as much,
you know what I mean?
Good work, keep working.
So it would be hard
for me to sort of like,
suddenly be like, "Oh, I'm lifted up
"by this wonderful life that I have."
I love it, but you know,
my feet are on the ground, you know?
It's, you know, it's work.
It's a job.
(loud whooshing air)
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Canif Ageric asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Elba's top 10 rules
meant the most to you,
is going to have the
biggest impact on your life.
Leave it in the comments.
I'll join the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(loud explosion)
- I do think that, you
know, it is a balancing act
and the truth is, it's
about forward planning,
having a good team around
you, you know what I mean?
To help me and help me see perspective
because one thing about being in the front
is that you can't see what's behind you,
but if you've got people
that are around you
to give you a little bit of vision,
you can go, "All right, okay.
"Actually, this will work
and this won't work,"
you know what I mean?
But when you're just
looking forward sometimes,
you won't see that.
- [Interviewer] When you
realized it wasn't a joke,
was your first instinct stay away from it?
Or was it percolating in the
back of your head somewhere
as a great idea?
- It was a couple of things happening
and my first instinct was, "Dude, dude.
"That is the opportunity of a lifetime.
"Are you kidding me?
"What a gift."
But then, it was the next thought was,
"But if you fuck it up, goodnight.
"Your career is over,
"period."
You know?
Because in film, you know, my career
has been decent and I
can't say I have a string
of amazing films under my belt, you know?
I think I've got great films and films
that vary from popcorn films
to some really heartfelt films,
but you know, Mandela
was the next level for me
and it was absolutely the
gateway to the next chapter
of my career.
But had I had to the
gateway and tripped up
as I fall in, I wouldn't,
I won't be moving on
because he's such a big,
world, global citizen,
you know?
And I had all this sort of trepidation
about you know, "Shit man, I
don't look like Mr. Mandela
"at all.
"How in the hell am I going to do this?"
But Justin was really
clear about his vision
and then it was a different spin, I guess.
- What is our theory in success?
what is your mantra around this?
- You know, it's a good question.
I don't know if I've actually
ever thought about success
in that way.
Obviously, I feel a successful actor,
but I also felt successful the first day
I got my first job.
You know, that was a form of success.
I think ultimately,
if you're successful in whatever you do,
it's about maintenance, isn't it?
That, I think, is the most important thing
is maintaining success.
You know, you get to the pinnacle,
but how do you stay up there?
And that, I think, is important.